welcome to this video a 15 minute game
and one a4 was played let's see let's
play the cow cow I haven't played this
on video often if at all so for the sake
of some great team okay let's see what
we get a power form just the normal
exchange the exchange line so 96
attacking deformed know why protected
yeah Quincy seven I think this is some a
bit more interesting than I def success
Quincy's having prevent special perform
yeah now I'm i can simply develop this
Bishop to g4 and continue with ecigs
probably young lee 6mb should be six
this is very similar to them I'm Queens
gambit exchange of course okay not f1 he
probably wants to get nigerian h3 plate
so that he will get them my bishop on g4
yeah that's what's hard to prevent but
also not not a big deal
okay so probably I will I will take on
on a three plays h3 could I play
something else just quickly checking
night age 59 h5 could be an idea I know
so maybe maybe possible so that on age
three I can take g3 and to win hmm looks
a bit unnatural this move well but it
fights us main idea probably let's let's
try this right now I'm castles I could
take on g3 or I could play Bishop t6 and
also possibility this kind of stuff
night h5 in Santa is of course a
somewhat somewhat slow it's not
especially developing so Bishop d6 now
right you should be fine completing
development neither for us also the
possibility of course but after just
capsular ok maybe not afore I could have
been at it for but also threatened to
take it now maybe this would have been
better the should be 6 watts loop i
played this a bit too quickly
okay nothing terrible happened but
neither for us maybe better should have
thought about this at least okay so uh
huh H dream okay I'm okay once the
castle probably entered saying on h2 so
what does what now I mean I've know a
particular problems um I needed to be
cautious though her castle sure they can
probably take on h7 King takes Knight g5
checking g6 and g4 I probably lose so
shouldn't I shouldn't Castle really the
question is what else Bishop g6 like a
play Bishop g6 exchanges some exchanging
the bishop is probably a good idea but
he could play Bishop e2 in response not
that is terribly dangerous but I'm not
sure that I can exchange the bishops yes
though this looks desirable structure
from a structured point if you still my
bed Bishop with pawns on f7 65 but of
course it's not bad really so just a
theoretical thing that can be of
importance in the in the end game okay
just you just canceled ok so just castle
myself probably mamady could maybe take
and play on 95 this can be a problem ok
now I'll grab this diagram this then now
just castles yeah lagi 5 I can probably
answer with g6 the sub shouldn't be a
problem
and ya know my general idea would be em
probably em to go from the well-known
minority attack with b5 ok yeah made
seven it's not much of a choice I need
to play the smooth I didn't think that
this is really a problem for me that's
g6 not it's not really weak can always
after let's say rook c8 or rugby 8
rookie ate whatever i can drop back the
bishop to fh and and cover the kingside
also if i feel that this is necessary
and still I've got b5 long-term issue
really could be as Bishop his bishop
only three which is rather bad piece ok
so night i go into g4 probably Queen g4
h4 this could be M could be as idea one
idea for me could be to bring in Knight
to f5 this will also help to protect
them the King side but its own it's a
dangerous Quincy form i'm not sure i
think i can still react to Queen g wifee
really wants to play it want to get
something going on the queenside also
with b5 and we can play a 4 but then i
could play a six and insist on playing
b5 some hard for him to really prevent
it i also still have this 97 f 5 yeah of
course he insists on on this Queen h4 I
could reply with h5 but then g44 white
and this looks looks shaky
alright so let's say 50 typical idea is
Quinn h4 h5 g4 then if I'm a [ __ ] on
g7 to play group a jade but not sure
that I can can get this get this going
okay the ideal Queen h4 h5 g4 okay Jade
so we are what why just trying to get
something I think it did I have a hard
time believing that this should be
dangerous but ok needs to do something
yeah probably tweenage fri it's not
really leading to to anything age 5 g 40
page 8a some even even a problem with
what is swype playing after this i
threatened to take on young let's see it
g4 okay Jade I'm threatening to take on
g4 damages his pawn structure even more
I mean you cannot play a position with
takes on g4 and queens affordances this
is simply far too weak 97 f 5 and so on
so g4 ok Jade's would be should be very
good for black and if he doesn't play G
forward towards White's idea you could
do is not f3 and then play Bishop g5
Bishop g5 to have success with p.m. in
fact a good idea neither three looks
like a good movie amande Bishop g5
probably on idea three I would would go
would be five Bishop g5 and then
probably Bishop e7 I cannot allow p ship
f6 and sis are too dangerous yeah this
could be a could be a possible move I
mean wide them certainly shouldn't be um
yeah clearly were see how anything mmm
but this I don't know f4 really this
killed sis Bishop a completely killed
special mm-hmm so what is a good defense
IAM what i want to do is I want to put
an ad on f5 of course the plane I t 7
and aldon the Queen probably drops back
to 22 f2 and all night f5 he would play
G for him maybe
yeah what would help me if I would would
ensure that i am I get a pawn to H form
to secure night on f5 so maybe rook h8
if the green movement i play age form
and this secures the f5 square I Drive
my threat now it's 97 f 5 + h form if i
get to this then this should be very
good for me with this some eternal night
on f5 which you cannot expel in any way
maybe queen f2 are also not possible I
thought Queen f2h 493 but then I can
even take a form besides the fact that i
could play we should be seven but taking
on a foursome is even stronger so I'm
not sure what to see what is he playing
now of course as mentioned my real
planners red be five but I need to
address the king said first this is more
important if I'm able to UM to close the
King side and get an ID to or to f5 then
it's a it's basically over why then
would have absolutely no no play at all
I'm not sure what
you what you should do really well
really this looks strange to me night a
seven even threatens night at five water
with winning the queen i played this
really quickly hope that's not there's
no devilish trickier because otherwise
i'm simply very good no not at five
threatening to win the Queen and what is
he doing probably okay yeah okay let's
get to our five ya know needs to play am
Queen and Queen there exactly and kh4
would be normal now but maybe I have
something better even let's look quickly
I don't think so okay Mitch for so now
the night on f5 is so it's really a rock
cannot be driven away each for those
kind of structures can be slightly weak
but it's at the moment protected two
times and not attacked even once so the
King side is completely secure now and
very nicely am configured from blacks
point of view so now I can also one take
care about them the Queen side I'm not
really sure what you should do and a
possibility could be to increase
pressure on edge for but I don't see how
okay they probably once this is a good
idea maybe Bishop to see one and then
trying to get something going only six
Bishop see one root x e6 for example
quite quite simple but itself at least
an idea
or b-five is some part of my plan anyway
yeah now with threatening rupee 6m need
to attend to that question is how Queen
Queen somewhere Quincy six maybe not
sure I don't want to spend a lot large
amount of time on that this it's
probably not so pond where I go okay
maybe now Knight takes rook takes and
then on g6 may need to be a bit cautious
Mme um I'm really a really a nicely
positioned here but still it's not not
an easy win okay let's protect us please
look each other then just maybe 27 I
mean this is just safe and should be
fine yeah it's not so easy I mean black
is good but how do you really make
progress a five before yeah probably but
it's not not completely easy a five
phone must be okay certainly fits into
the general scheme of things hmm alright
so what does he try to do take on g6 and
then take on e6 now something like this
maybe okay what I shouldn't do is to
take out this is clear cannot take this
so that sounds the Queen I
take it would take with the f porn and
then Bishop g5 f6 on and so on this
would be really a disaster yeah yeah
probably a Plymouth before next I'd like
to have some more reinforcements okay
he's covering reform so that I cannot
play it instantly what about Quincy for
just attacking a two and DDP three is
this possible very crude but not I don't
see at the moment what what's the
problem let's try yeah Costigan to get
do that but it's not exactly a scary
this move so now let's play before I
need to do this at some point and might
as well do it now if you were to take on
before now than the default phone what
they would fall so what cannot really
take
yes but this would lead to a little
position where this pawn is really weak
as he cannot cannot capture recapture
with the pawn so why do I go b5 or mc6
not sure let's go here it's probably not
much of a difference at the end the
Queen will probably be unknown on b6
anyway to put pressure on the on the
pony on d4 okay so loud default just
hang and I can further increase pressure
the Queen on b5 also covers d3 so he
cannot play 93 mmm okay so multitude a
firm moves now let's check what's what's
the best I'm taking immediately as
probably am probably not not the best I
could go with the bishop to f6 which
would be good taking d 4 i'm only not
sure about the move like we need to
probably this would help to consolidate
i like to take the CFR ruling first and
then I asked the left Queen B 6 and
Bishop to f6 will be very tough for him
to to keep our his material here many
tactics and don't see see yet could go I
could think about rooks III though rook
33 how does does he answer that Bishop
Bishop to d2 not exactly a great move
yeah this is looking very comfortable
now it's got just this weaknesses on
fynd form and all blacks pieces have
good positions the bishop one is six as
mentioned would like to be on f6 but on
d6 the term attacks f form it's also not
not too bad okay so the idea was to drop
back now to the seventh or sixth rank to
gain tempo on doubling on the C file and
g4 is now again hanging so he needs to
attend to that yeah the night but it
just just passive got the C file now
with Roxy to as a possible improvement
next move yeah this is so quite a static
white why cannot move really cannot
improve his position our pieces are
passive looks it too is so very very
simple idea at that is quite effective
so rootsy to the night doesn't even have
a square on e 2 so how does see how to
see cover the h upon I guess it doesn't
oh ok I didn't didn't see this at all
funny aha this is a sick trick that this
this son would be working is really sick
but it seems to be the case yeah it's
the decking on so taking here on this on
this rook and green light a5 is a check
of course so if i take on f2 it would
you can as an intermediate check here
it's that way to to sacrifice the
exchange and some some good good fashion
and I don't see it crazy
yeah Ruby c1 is also get this
intermediate check so probably rootsy to
wasn't wasn't the best I mean okay it's
still a big big advantage for blackbird
so still I probably had something better
I think because of this move I'm still
better because Quincy two is coming he
still got the weaknesses but of course
this helped him quite a bit Quincy to is
probably exchanging and playing rookie
to ya a shame that I didn't see this
move Naji three really is that it wasn't
sick move and this was working so
strange okay clong clong so what about
this end game is this it's probably just
equal hard to see how would make any
progress okay anytime just stay stay on
the sea far I want the King to protect
the pawn them now I'm attacking deform
at some not really am not really
something to play for us like
just ah are just shuffling at the moment
trying to find some improvement okay you
cannot enter on the C file so i could
maybe try to make progress as well okay
so at the end it comes to f6 and e5 not
much else that I can do so the king is
it good on c64 this advance no no f's x
+ f6 and e5 of course I mean he's got
two weaknesses on f ing for so if I was
not really am the most logical kind of
way to make any headway but still okay
maybe I can get the rookie now to do it
anyway anywhere hard way is simply
trying to do nothing and make a draw at
the end yeah unfortunately am this might
be possible okay some we didn't continue
to chase the rook from evil which he
tries now probably to win on time so
which is I don't think I'm rather funny
human year he played down completely
passive the whole game and now somebody
is ambitious and tries to win of course
on time not on position not quite sure
what this is probably is a force bad
makes my bishop look funny but this
Bishop is also also somewhat strange
a water game the opponent doing nothing
the whole game tries to load on time and
so on but now I've got it check check
check check check check all right yeah
if we found this the sick move 93-year
unbelievable I mean this was really to
do so nice and and now this move this is
sick really sick 93 year whereas odd did
I overlooked something a computer once
supply Roxy one with plus 11 what what
did that we'll look here I don't get it
at all I can simply take on till I'm so
stupid i can just take on c1 why didn't
that take on c1 this nice nice
completely hallucinating here of course
yeah I didn't he didn't have a move
there as I see why did not take on c1
this is just completely completely
simply simply winning that oh my god
after all this it was so nice yeah what
is lost here you cannot really move
anything and while this of course
shouldn't work at all and now the after
this i'm still okay but i mean i miss
the better
the other move rookie one just wins wins
material for nothing and then after
after I even exchanged Queens which I
shouldn't have done probably it's a draw
you can simply stay yeah and then okay
it was some sort of scramble at the end
to which I won but ok this was a
terrible game I really should just take
see one I mean why why and why are still
that takes you one I've got five minutes
on the clock they just rip see one yeah
thanks for watching I hope you liked it
anyway it was pretty instructive up to
this point but really is really sick
that I didn't take this alright thanks
for watching